Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
ChatGPT has just been supercharged with
browsing support, I tried it myself too,
and I think this changes everything. Well, almost
everything, as you will see in a moment. And this
is going to be an incredible journey, so
hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars.
You see, normally, ChatGPT with GPT-3.5
has read a great deal of the huge body
of text in the internet, and therefore
it knows a lot. It can help us with so
much. But there is a problem. What it the
problem? Well, it can help us so much,
if whatever we are looking for happened before
September 2021. Anything after that is a no-go.
Until today, because now we have live
browsing support. Let’s see together
what this is good for! Now, perhaps the
world’s best two investment experts,
Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger just held their
annual meeting where they discuss investing,
the economy and more. As always, it is a
treasure trove of information, however,
look. It is more than 7 hours long. So, it
is time! It is time for what exactly? Well,
for asking the new ChatGPT to summarize it for
us and see if it is worth the time investment!
First, it starts browsing browsing browsing,
and then. Ouch. Unfortunately, it cannot
watch videos, which is understandable.
Second try, oh my goodness. It is
hallucinating. Calm down, little AI,
this is not a video of a startup called Mindgrasp
AI. It’s all right. Now I am wondering, does this
startup exist or did it make it up? It can tell
us what it is, and I checked, it indeed exists.
Third try, sigh. It also fails. But wait a
minute! This time it fails a little differently.
Look! A ray of hope! It can look up transcripts
instead and summarize those. Yes please! And,
let’s see…great! They talked a lot
about human nature, that is my favorite,
so I’ll definitely watch this. We could probably
even ask for the appropriate time stamps if
something specific caught our eye. So, you see, it
works, but sometimes it is a bit eccentric. Yes,
we have an eccentric, genius AI at
our disposal. What a time to be alive!
But wait, if it can browse, it can also
help us with other things. For instance,
it can visit our coding projects, have a look
at our work, and even suggest improvements.
You see a ton of new code here, but it is
a bit unclear what it has changed and what
it is trying to do. No matter, look! It
summarizes the nature of the changes and
also tells us why it has done what it
has done. That is absolutely amazing.
And if the database cutoff is not in September
2021 anymore, we can ask about things that
take place today. So, market research time!
How did the US interest rates change in the
last 3 months? That is a great and concise
summary, with citations. Loving it. Now,
tell me the story of interest rates in
the last 10 years. We get a lot of data,
I like it, and even better, lots of
additional blinking cursors for free.
Now let’s do some actual market research and
ask what the economy looked like last time
the US had interest rates like this. And
then, our whimsical genius is at it again.
I tried again, and then it says that interest
rates looked like this last time around 2006
and 2007. And it ran out of time before it
could make a table with the appropriate data,
but it kindly asks if it can
try again. Of course, and,
good job little AI! Bravo! We now have some
numbers to compare these two situations. Now,
I hope it goes without saying, please do
not invest on this data, I just ran this
toy experiment to see a little clearer what is
going on and where we are in the debt cycle.
So that was market research, and now, it
is time for research research. Namely,
I would love to know if there are real
scientific experiments about guitars. Now,
what experiment am I looking for? I am looking
for something about tonewoods. This is something
that has been a subject of intense debate among
artists who use electric guitars. You see,
manufacturers love to sell you all kinds of
woods they use for the guitar body and neck
and they say it makes a great deal of difference
in the sound they make. Perhaps it does. However,
we are Fellow Scholars over here, so we would
like to see hard evidence of that. But for me,
no luck. I don’t quite understand why, but I never
found a real paper on this topic. Until today,
because ChatGPT was able to browse its way
into a proper paper that is about exactly that.
Oh my. Here is the setup of the paper, where
they actually done precise measurements on
what sounds these guitars make if they
are made of different kinds of woods.
And the result is. My goodness, can that
really be? This seems to suggest that they
indeed make a difference at least
in this particular setup. However,
we can ask our resident genius, ChatGPT
to read the paper and summarize it for us.
And then, ouch. It couldn’t read the paper. But
it’s almost all text and it is right over there.
Still, nothing. Alright, so let’s give it the
abstract, results and discussion parts of the
paper as plain text, and ask the same question
again. And, bam! There we go! The body and the
neck both seem to make a difference. But it
still uses a great deal of technical jargon,
so let’s ask it to summarize it for a 10-year
old. And I think the result is excellent. It
compares the body of the guitar to the body of
a car and how it goes vroom. I love it. Clearly,
the comparison has its limits,
but still, I am very impressed.
Also, every study has its own limitations.
Let’s ask it what those are - I am very excited
to see this, so let’s see. Oh come on! Let me
cultivate my addiction. So, quite a bit later,
we get this. And I have to say that this
is an excellent assessment of the paper,
especially that it only read parts of it. In
short, these are just two types of wood and in
laboratory conditions, and a bunch more
great insights. I absolutely love this.
So this is the story of our little eccentric
genius. It can summarize videos that are many
hours long, be a coding teacher, do market
research, research research, and a ton more.
And I bet that just one or two more papers down
the line, and it will be way faster and more
reliable. And for me - this paper refers to dozens
of previous works, so I can have a glorious time
going through them and learning a ton. Thanks
ChatGPT, I can’t wait! What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!